le caire avec ses 20 millions
d'habitants est devenue la capitale d'un
nouveau phénomène la bimbo maniaque
une nouvelle génération de chanteuses
sexy qui défraie la chronique avec leur
clip aguicheur et leurs poses lascives
un phénomène présent un peu partout dans
le quotidien des égyptiens mais aussi
dans les autres sociétés arabes
les affiches et les panneaux
publicitaires à l'éffigie de ses stars
contraste avec la réalité des femmes
dans les rues ici 80 % des femmes
portent le voile qu'on appelle le hidjab
ou le voile intégral qu'on appelle le
niqab mais les bimbos d'orient se sont
surtout fait connaître via les paraboles
et les chaînes satellitaires qui diffuse
en continu leur clip sexy elle incarne
le nouveau fantasme des pays arabes
elles illustrent le paradoxe des
sociétés du moyen-orient partagé entre
ce désir de liberté et de l'autre la
contrainte du cadre religieux mais
aujourd'hui ces jeunes stars doivent
aussi affronter la pression sociale et
la mise à l'index par les islamistes la
pression intégristes a déjà eu raison du
cinéma de la danse et d'autres domaines
culturels
dans ce contexte ces chanteuses sont
devenus un échappatoire dans une société
de plus en plus fermé les printemps
arabes permettront quai de libérer la
société
alors qu'aujourd'hui les révolutions
arabes semblent profiter aux islamistes
peut-on craindre pour ses chanteuses qui
repousse sans cesse les limites
nous suivrons les égyptiennes
rubis et 110 nous verrons pourquoi elle
défraie la chronique et comment
fonctionne ce marché et pourquoi ce
phénomène est le dernier espace de
liberté dans une société qui s'est figé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sandy est l'une de ces nouvelles
chanteuses à 23 ans à peine avec déjà
trois albums derrière elle elle s'est
essentiellement fait connaître à travers
ses clips où elle n'hésite pas à
s'afficher le plus dénudée possible une
attitude qui fait scandale
je suis à dix la bombe égyptienne je
reste d'une popularité mondiale comme
beyoncé rihanna ou lady gaga
mes chansons ont été l'objet d'une
controverse parce que je me concentre
dans mes clips essentiellement sur
l'aspect corporelle c'est ce sur quoi je
travaille en priorité
chaque ligue 1 barthow que ce soit le
look latitudes où l'apparence physique
je m'intéresse à tous ces détails je me
sens sur pas si on voit des partis dont
le succès repose essentiellement là
dessus une attitude qui contraste et
fait scandale car les stars du
proche-orient ressembler à cela il y
encore quelques années une allure chaste
et des paroles romantiques
[Musique]
mais aujourd'hui la nouvelle génération
affiche un autre style qui n'a plus rien
à voir
les chanteuses bimbo affichent leur
plastique plantureuse et leurs
chorégraphies
une attitude que 110 revendique comme
une forme d'émancipation juste trop
libre en ce qui concerne ma manière de
m'habiller et d'être c'est rose et par
rapport à ce qu'ils connaissent et ce
qu'ils définissent comme critère en
général la fille égyptienne a des rêves
limitée qui vont s'arrêter au mariage
suis libre et j'aspire à plus que ce que
la société veut bien de proposer ou que
je puisse arriver j'en voudrai toujours
plus la vision de 110 n'est pas en odeur
de sainteté chez les frères musulmans
qui exercent un poids grandissant dans
la société et dans la vie politique du
pays à la confrérie
le responsable des affaires culturelles
s'oppose formellement à l'imagerie de
ces chanteuses
[Musique]
l'art doit avoir un cadre moral
il n'est pas utile de faire des scènes
de nu et d'appeler cela dollar ça ne
correspond pas et ne convient pas aux
moeurs et aux règles de vie de notre
peuple
il faut observer les règles de la pudeur
de respect de soi et de réserve
la règle du voile doit être respectée je
parle du hidjab le voile qui couvre la
tête et pas du voile intégral le niqab
voilà ce que nous défendons mais nous ne
voulons pas l'imposer nous voulons que
ce soit le peuple qui accompagne ce
choix l'exemple de sondhi est loin
d'être marginal ce phénomène des bimbos
s'est banalisé
[Applaudissements]
si aujourd'hui 110 et d'autres
chanteuses se lance dans ce nouveau
créneau
c'est grâce à cette jeune femme
ruby elle est devenue à la fois un
phénomène de société est l'une des
personnalités les plus controversées en
egypte j'ai toujours aimé danser devant
le miroir dans l'intimité pour ma mère
et ma tante je reprenais des vieux
morceaux et cela ne posait pas de
problème et puis c'est devenu un métier
sont vraiment y réfléchir sans que ce
soit prémédité elle est étayée et là
c'est devenu plus compliqué on est dans
une société conservatrice
donc les critères d'appréciation de
l'art sont hypocrites la danse la
chanson ça fait partie de la tradition
du pays
le problème c'est qu'on veut mélanger la
religion à cela et je me suis très vite
heurtés à cette réalité c'est sans doute
ma spontanéité qui a dû choquer une
liberté affirmait jusque dans ses clips
son premier titre littéralement pu c'est
pourquoi la montre dans les rues de
prague en danseuse du ventre
ce sera le clip le plus diffusé sur les
chaînes du moyen-orient et sa carrière
sera définitivement lancée rubis choc et
déchaîne les passions
et dans les rues du caire les avis sont
tranchés et les réactions ne se font pas
attendre elle ne représente pas d'intrus
culture qu'elle fait n'a rien à voir
avec l'egypte ne me choque pas
délicieuse et ses chansons sont belles
elle est très jolie et s'habille bien
j'ai acheté son dernier album j'aime
bien ces clips et sa manière de bouger
avec le succès rubis s'est construit une
solide base de contradicteurs et
certains se sont élevées contre elle
c'est le cas de cet homme
nabil al-wahsh il est avocat et pour
l'huile lutter contre la diffusion de
ces chanteuses est un engagement civique
et citoyen ces clips ont fait voler en
éclats les fondamentaux de la famille
égyptienne
ce ne sont même pas des clips mais des
sexes clip comme on les appelle ici je
me suis battu devant les tribunaux pour
faire interdire la diffusion de ce sac
ce clip j'ai gagné mais malheureusement
la décision de justice n'a jamais été
indiqué rubis vie dans ce quartier
excentré du caire un quartier
résidentiel et huppé
salut voici mon immeuble sac mariama
belle j'habite ici depuis deux ans dans
le quartier de heliopolis et tous ces
gens ce sont mes voisins et les hôtesses
des voisins ont reconnu la star
il engage la conversation tu vis au
liban pourquoi je vis je ne l'avais
jamais vu ici c'est tourne en ce moment
en tournée
ah si un type thuraya le dernier clip il
vient d'être finie c'est celui avec
cette danse qui fait comme ça sur un son
de house music et toi tu aimes ce que
fait rubim c'est agréable ce qu'elle
fait mais je ne sais pas trop quoi dire
là comme ça si tu n'aimes pas ce qu'elle
fait tu peux le dire aimer ce qu'elle
fait pas totalement mais dire que je
n'aime pas ce qu'elle fait je ne peux
pas dire cela non plus ça suffit rubis a
marqué les esprits avec ses clips
tout le monde en a parlé et c'est
parfois dur de se faire un avis
si c'est bien ou non elle est d'autant
plus appréciée qu'elle a des détracteurs
je dirais
elle est connue pour être passé dans la
zone rouge comme on dit mais en libye
pour vous est ce qu'elle incarne la
jeune femme moderne égyptienne obéir au
but disons qu'elle est sophistiqué c'est
plus une icône est quelqu'un de
différent qui n'a pas froid aux yeux et
c'est pour ça que ça marche
les filles que tu croise tous les jours
ne sont pas aussi libre aussi
sophistiquée en somme tu vois ce que je
veux dire
mais ici en egypte je ne connais aucune
femme qui soit comme ça qui n'est pas
froid aux yeux
stop
je ne veux pas que tu me colle comme ça
nous ne parviendrons pas savoir
réellement ce que pensent ces jeunes
hommes timides public et peut-être un
peu honteux face à celle qui est devenu
un fantasme parfois coupable en egypte
les rapports hommes femmes ne sont pas
évidents et ce même chez les jeunes
rubis vient de sortir son nouveau clip
avec une chorégraphie qui a eu un
retentissement sans précédent maintenant
je vais à la gym
je vais faire des exercices et répétées
des mouvements de la chorégraphie pour
mon clip
un clip qui a de nouveau fait scandale
pour comprendre
nous la suivons dans la salle de gym
cette partie de la chorégraphie à
caractère sexuel a été effacé sur le
tournage même du clip par la commission
du film mais même amputé d'une partie de
leurs chorégraphies
les clips de rugby sont devenues un
problème politique qui a trouvé une
résonance jusqu'à l'assemblée nationale
les frères musulmans ont été les
premiers à réagir et hamdi hassan
représentants du parti fondamentaliste
s'en est vivement pris à la chanteuse
c'est ici le siège des frères musulmans
nous sommes 90 députés
et c'est ici que nous réunissons il a
tenté de faire interdire les clips de
ruby mais en vain nous lui montrons les
images d'un des derniers tubes de ruby
mais il n'est pas très bavard sur la
chanteuse dont il refuse même de
prononcer le nom
[Musique]
c'est précisément ce que nous refusons
cette culture cette pensée sont contre
l'islam l'islam n'aime pas ce genre de
choses et nous nous ne considérons pas
cela comme de l'art si ça c'est de l'art
nous sommes contre adam en nous le
refusons première force d'opposition
dans le pays
l'influencent des frères musulmans est
de plus en plus visible en egypte ils
manifestent pour un retour fondamentale
aux valeurs de l'islam et chez eux
les chanteuses bimbo ne sont pas en
odeur de sainteté je n'aime pas ce
qu'elle représente
je n'aime pas ce type de musique est ce
qu'elle raconte l'équipe sont proposés
c'est vulgaire ce que j'aime le moins ce
sont leurs tenues vestimentaires et les
post qu'elle prenne ça va trop loin
[Musique]
aujourd'hui ces jeunes stars doivent
affronter à la fois la pression des
intégristes mais aussi la pression
sociale et parfois même familiale
rubis a vécu tout cela elle nous a donné
rendez vous ce soir dans un bar branché
de la capitale où elle a l'habitude de
se rendre
[Musique]
elle a convié sa soeur et ses cousins et
se remémore la mise en garde qui lui
avait été faite au début ma famille ne
voulait pas que je devienne chanteuse
elle me répétait sans cesse que le
milieu artistique n'est pas le nôtre que
la chanson c'était péché contraire à
l'esprit de la religion je n'ai pas
écouté tout ce qu'on disait parce que
l'essentiel pour moi c'est d'être en
conformité avec les désirs
je veux faire plaisir à ma famille mais
sans renier les envies profondes
quand notre famille a vu le succès de
rubis grandir auprès du public nous
sommes plus opposés à ce qu'elle fait
nous les avons juste dit de faire
attention c'est un milieu réputé
dangereux et amoral malgrè la rigidité
de la société égyptienne
rubis 110 et les autres égéries de la
pop arabe bénéficie d'un large canal de
diffusion via les paraboles et les
chaînes de clips qui diffuse du liban et
des états les plus libéraux du golfe
mais aussi des gîtes
[Musique]
au caire voici le siège de magique l'une
de ces nouvelles chaînes qui diffusent
24 heures sur 24 c'est clip controversé
des clips qui parviennent à cohabiter
dans des sociétés qui se radicalise et
pour le patron de la chaîne si facile à
expliquer cette mode des clips sexuelle
comme on les appelle ici
comment s'appelle ce marché se développe
de plus en plus car ils expriment la
frustration de la société en effet la
pornographie est illégale ici
aujourd'hui un réalisateur pour garantir
le succès de son clip commence d'abord
par réfléchir aux éléments sexuels qu'il
pourra se permettre
le paradoxe entre modernité et tradition
s'incarne jusque dans les rues du caire
dans les rues commerçantes cohabitent
sans problème femmes voilées et
boutiques de dessous sexy
une image forte qui illustre la dualité
des sociétés du moyen-orient sont des
l'egypte contemporaine c'est aussi en
sonder les antagonismes les
contradictions et les paradoxes
[Musique]
je
dans les beaux quartiers les étudiants
égyptiens côtoie le petit monde des
expatriés c'est l'égypte des privilégiés
on y organise des soirées où on peut
boire de l'alcool et échanger librement
rim et égyptienne et francophones pour
elle ces stars on voit la question de
l'interdît et de la transgression
c'est ce qu'on veut bien faire mais on
peut pas faire on peut pas faire à cause
d'après sur la société à cause d'après
son conte comics nous mêmes auteurs de
long sur yon et autour de nous on se
retrouve donc les fans oui bien sûr que
tu t'es pas mal de sa vie comme guy
elles veulent être des stars très belle
dirais pas les mecs et les mec pareil
donc tout le monde veut être comme ça va
avoir la liberté mais ça je paierai pas
trop de rentrer dans les détails puisque
j'ai trouvé je ne sais pas vraiment ces
chanteuses cristallise la dualité et
l'ambivalence de la société égyptienne
un phénomène amplifié par la
médiatisation qu'elle connaisse 110 à
terminer son marathon promotionnel et
elle se livre avec nous à l'énumération
des couvertures de magazines qu'elle a
pu faire en l'espace de deux ans
[Applaudissements]
manga c'est le magazine rotana ils ont
écrit la bombe de la chanson égyptienne
j'étais satisfait de cette couverture ça
c'est le rendez vous c'est une parution
en mon honneur au titre du nouvel espoir
de la chanson
ils ont écrit samedi à des rêves sans
limite
cette phrase écrit moi et l'amour
lorsque c'était à mes débuts et on
imaginait plein de choses sur moi mais
l'article est quand même sympa
l'aïe a marqué je compte sur mon
physique car c'est un passeport pour la
célébrité
j'ai beaucoup misé sur l'attrait
physique c'est vrai mais il faut aussi
qu'on s'intéresse à mes chansons en
proposant aux maladies
sandy tenait à nous montrer son dernier
clip tourné cet été à paris
[Musique]
aurait-il été possible de tourner avec
cette tenue ici dans les rues du caire
impossible je pense ça n'aurait pas été
possible de tourner un clip comme celui
ci en egypte
parce qu'aujourd'hui les gens ne sont
pas habitués à voir des filles aussi peu
habillée comme moi et bien sûr
j'aimerais pas créer de troubles et
surtout être victime de quelque chose
sondhi fait directement référence à deux
événements qui ont touché deux stars de
la bimbo magna
l'ambivalence à l'encontre de ces
chanteuses pris un virage tragique
alors que la chanteuse libanaise marois
se produisait au caire pour un concert
son public masculin est devenue
frénétique
il attrape la chanteuse et la tripote
littéralement elle parviendra à s'enfuir
en pleurs escorté par la police après
qu'on lui a arraché une partie de ses
vêtements
personne ne sera arrêtée mais ce fait
divers n'est pas isolé
[Musique]
la danseuse du ventre que l'on voit ici
dina est aussi actrice invitée au
festival du film du caire il ya quelques
années
dean a esquissé un déhanchement dans la
rue suite à cela les sommes excités par
son geste se sont livré à des
attouchements et des violences sur les
femmes qu'ils attrapent et dans la
hausse siège des frères musulmans le
député hamdi hassan réagi pour lui c'est
très clair les coupables sont les stars
et le gouvernement
c'est un incident regrettable mais ce
sont des jeunes désoeuvrés au chômage on
les a volontairement excité cela traduit
le délabrement moral et économique de
l'egypte le gouvernement est responsable
de cette situation
la société ne nous considèrent pas comme
des êtres humains
la société se montrent parfois hostile à
ce qu'on fait comme si nous n'étions
qu'un fantasme alors que nous sommes
pourvus d'une sensibilité d'une
réflexion
les critiques sont souvent blessantes
on le place au coeur d'un débat qui est
politique et je veux juste faire savoir
que nous ne sommes pas en rock et que
nous faisons partie intégrante de la
société égyptienne
certains disent que toi comme d'autres
chanteuses vous ne respectez pas les
moeurs du peuple égyptien que votre
activité va à l'encontre de l'islam te
considères tu comme une bonne musulmane
j'en suis une
on veut opposer ce que je fais à la
bonne morale et la vertu des femmes
voilées mais je connais des femmes qui
portent le voile et qui ont des actions
répréhensibles
ça ma foi est une relation entre moi et
dieu c'est une relation privée et ça
doit rester dans la sphère du privé
cette pression sociale va s'arrêter et
je pense que l'on doit défendre cela
avec la révolution le peuple va avoir
l'occasion de choisir et j'espère que ça
ira dans le sens de l'ouverture pour que
chaque égyptien puisse enfin jouir de sa
liberté depuis l'année dernière
l'egypte vit un passage important de son
histoire la révolution a permis de
mettre fin à la dictature de moubarak
et aujourd'hui le peuple égyptien doit
identifier pour quel modèle de société
il va opter pour une théocratie à la
saoudienne où la charia la loi islamique
en sera le fondement ou bien une
démocratie à la turque qui concilie
laïcité et islam
la question reste ouverte et sur la
place tahrir le débat est houleux entre
laïcs et islamistes salafistes qui
prônent un islam dur c'est le drapeau de
l'islam
pas celui du royaume saoudien il n'y a
de dieu que dieu et mohamed est son
prophète
il n'y a de dieu que dieu et mohamed est
son prophète
ce n'est pas le drapeau de l'arabie
saoudite
c'est le symbole de l'islam le drapeau
de tous les musulmans
il n'y a de dieu que dieu
là c'est le drapeau de tous les
musulmans mais le symbole de l'islam ce
n'est pas l'épée de ton drapeau
l'islam n'est pas arrivée par la force
c'est une pensée et une conception ça
c'est le drapeau de l'arabie c'est un
modèle brutale dont nous voulons pas
tuer musulmane
tu te dis musulmane alors je n'ai rien à
faire avec toi je n'ai rien à faire si
tu n'es pas à musulmane je les tiens à
te dire nous retrouvons rubis dans les
locaux de sa maison de disques pour elle
la société égyptienne doit aussi faire
sa révolution des moeurs et des
mentalités
mon message c'est celui de la liberté de
disposer de soi ce que je fais montre
qu'on peut disposer de soi ce que je
fais fait partie de l'héritage de ce
pays mythique ac b on veut nous mettre
dans la case de l'immoralité mais où va
notre société si on réprime tout ce qui
plaît si on s'insurge sur tout ce qui
fait partie de la vie si l'egypte a
toujours exporter sa musique son cinéma
et sa joie de vivre dans le reste du
monde arabe
le pays vit désormais sous l' influence
des prêches salafistes un islam durée
littéraliste influencé par l'arabie
saoudite
cette conception s'impose lentement mais
sûrement dans toutes les strates de la
société
cet islam jusque là confinée aux couches
populaires et aux couches moyennes de la
société touche désormais la bourgeoisie
cairote
à quelques rues de là où vit rugby dans
le quartier d'heliopolis ces jeunes
femmes au foulard très tendance vient
assister aux cours salafistes du docteur
magdane
et son discours est sans équivoque
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alif ben t'es fait dit non c'est une
méthode d'apprentissage pour lire le
coran il y a une manière et instant
particulier à respecter pour chaque
lettre l'autre la manière dont la lettre
sort c'est une note haute ou basse
apparaître de la musique vous comme ça
c'est trompeur mais ça n'en est pas en
réalité c'est une science en réalité qui
s'appelle le tadjik
pour moi c'est une obligation de bien
savoir lire le coran est de bien
comprendre et de bien l'appliquer dans
la vie et savoir vivre en conformité
avec ses enseignements et maintenant on
va lire le coran ensemble en utilisant
le tadjik
irina tourina ouattara
[Musique]
m
pour l'apa
celui qui lit le coran devrait être un
chanteur exceptionnel ou du moins
quelqu'un de doué pour la chanson non le
coeur du musulman il peut pas
intérieurement
gardez le les chansons et les éclats
stature le coran en même temps ou non
l'autre en ce qu'ils font c'est à la
danse vient d'avoir les chansons
entraîne la danse assez numéro deux
c'est la danse et puis en n1 et a2
d'ivresse troisième enfin ça peut finir
par je ne sais pas une perte de respect
la danse ça vient de 7 ans et se
distraire d'une manière la rúa live
c'est à dire perdre son temps et ne pas
invoquer alors un autre assez loin de
l'invocation de là et comment le célèbre
et qu'il est hautement une note polo
seul par l'invocation d'alors ans ne
peut que ressentir la paix la
tranquillité
la danse était une institution est une
tradition en egypte nous devions
initialement assister à un festival de
danse il devait avoir lieu dans un grand
hôtel de la capitale
d'abord conviés on ou des commandera car
on doutait de nos identités
finalement le festival sera maintenue
mais dans le plus grand secret pas peur
des salafistes son organisatrice rakia
hussein ancienne danseuse et professeur
de danse nous en donnera l'explication
une fois l'événement passé
c'est une année difficile je ne savais
pas que vous étiez des journalistes
étrangers
enfin de vrais journalistes jusqu'à
aujourd'hui je pensais que vous étiez
des salafistes nous avions peur pour les
danseuses c'est pourquoi j'ai fait
croire à l'annulation du festival
et je voulais que personne ne filme la
danse est devenue un sujet très sensible
en egypte a trouvé une danseuse qui
veulent témoigner est un vrai défi en
egypte après plusieurs pistes après
plusieurs refus nous nous rendons dans
l'un des quartiers populaires du caire
pour y rencontrer haifa danseuses
traditionnelles qui se produit encore
dans les mariages
[Musique]
elle a accepté de nous recevoir mais
nous la sentons tendu et inquiète
[Musique]
non on ne peut pas tourner ici je ne
peux pas c'est pas possible
[Musique]
elle préfère nous donner rendez vous
loin de chez elle car sa famille et le
voisinage ignore tout de son activité
alfa doit se produire ce soir dans un
mariage
nous la suivons là où elle a l'habitude
de se préparer c'est comme ma maison ici
quand je suis là je suis à l'aise c'est
ici dans ce salon de coiffure pas comme
les autres que les danseuses comme haïfa
se retrouvent pour se préparer
ici elle est à l'abri des regards est ce
que tu peux me mettre une couleur plus
foncée
cette couleur-là le rouge attend est ce
que tu as une couleur plus proche du
noir il y à celui là où celui ci
oui celui-là ligne moi je viens ici tous
les jours
enfin tous les jours où je travaille
sinon je reste chez moi toutes les
filles qui viennent ici sont danseuse
par contre les femmes au foyer il vient
pas ici ça risque de porter préjudice à
leur réputation
personne ne sait que je fais ce métier
il n'ya que ma mère qu'il sache depuis
le début
[Musique]
moi je fais juste le maquillage
après elles vont faire leurs affaires
pour haifa les chanteuses bimbo non pas
à affronter quotidiennement la réalité
des rues du caire et une pression
sociale constante
elle s'y est cette confrontation
quotidienne lui est de plus en plus
pénible car les préjugés ont la vie dure
ici les égyptiens à la base il n'ya pas
tous les danseuses qu'il dénigre une
femme qui marche dans la rue et qui
n'est pas voilée
ça suffit pour qu'elle s'attire des
remontrances alors si elle a des
vêtements moulants cours ou autres ils
vont l'avoir comme une extraterrestre
elle a critiqué ce sera mal vu alors si
on parle des danseuses c'est pire la
voir danser ça les choque comme s'il
n'avait jamais vu ça auparavant
pour moi c'est un travail comme un autre
les femmes aujourd'hui sont plus
véhémente que les hommes encore elle te
regarde mal et se posent des questions
est un sujet c'est quoi ton travail mais
ça ne les regarde par ici nous
interrogeons une autre danseuse elle ne
souhaite pas être filmés mais son
témoignage est éloquent sur les dangers
qu'ils encourent
quel âge à aujourd'hui vient d'avoir 25
ans le métier de danseuse est difficile
ici
en ce qui me concerne c'est facile
qu'est ce qui est facile parce que
j'aime la danse tout simplement pas
familier au courant donc tu sors que tu
rentre tard sans leur dire ce que tu
fais
oui mais il ne se doute pas que ce que
tu fais je ne vis pas avec mes parents
tu es marié ou pas non je ne suis pas en
fait tu n'as pas accepté contre le film
parce que tu as peur de ta famille si
jamais la femme il apprend qu est ce que
tu risques
je n'imagine pas je risquerais quoi en
fait
leenhardt sûrement mais c'est ton
travail tu ne fais rien de méchant
non c'est vrai pourquoi ils te créerait
des problèmes parce que ma famille ils
n'aiment pas cela mais ils savent quoi
alors
ils sont 110 yona liste douais coin ce
sont de fervents religieux
est ce qu'il considère la danse comme
illicites oui
haifa est prête elle est toujours
accompagné de son chauffeur et
accessoirement de son homme de main pour
parer à toute menace
elle ne prend plus de risques depuis
quelques années et se produit dans des
endroits qu'elle connaît déjà ou que
d'autres danseuses ont eu l'occasion de
tester
on ne voit pas partout
certains endroits sont dangereux pour
les danseuses il y à des endroits où il
est même interdit que les danseuses se
produise on ne travaille qu'avec des
habitués ou des gens qu'on nous a
recommandé si on n'entend qu'une
danseuse a eu des problèmes
alors on ne va plus là bas
mais l'éventualité d'un débordement est
toujours à envisager une fois arrivées
haifa doit faire vite pour ne pas
provoquer les ardeurs des plus jeunes
qui guettent dans la rue elle doit aussi
demandé au préalable que nous puissions
la suivre ça ne me dérange pas si il
reste 5 minutes avec moi après que je me
sois changé j'arrive très vite car ça ne
se fait pas que j'en attarde devant tous
ces hommes parce que je suis la seule
femme au milieu de tous ces hommes ce
n'est pas convenable et en plus je donne
changeait face à certains débordements
et à une pression sociale de plus en
plus forte
le régime à réglementer la tenue des
danseuses elles sont désormais soumises
à des règles strictes
il y à une loi en egypte sur la censure
pour les danseuses la danseuse doit
obligatoirement porter la voile est sur
le ventre et un short en dessous de la
robe la longueur doit aller jusqu au
tibia sans qu'on ait d'autres
indications
si jamais la danseuse est attrapé son
voile est elle à une amende
cette tenue si je suis obligé de la m
parce que ça ne se fait pas de marcher
dans la rue en tenue de danseuse
je sors de voitures avec et je note
qu'une fois sur scène uniquement lorsque
c'est mon taux de danser moi
personnellement je la gardais certaines
danseuses on enlève je préfère la garder
certaines danseuses l'enlève mais après
il se peut que ça dégénère
haifa pense à décrocher d'ici quelques
mois la pression sociale est trop forte
et dans un pays où l'insultent fille ou
fils de danseuse est lourde de sens
haifa préféré arrêter avant que sa fille
n'ait à souffrir de la raillerie des
autres enfants
j'ai décidé d'arrêter ce travail à la
fin de l'année
je ne veux pas que plus tard on découvre
mon métier et qu'on finisse par traiter
ma fille deux filles de danseuses ça me
serait insupportable
c'est la pire insulte ici on sait signal
fac elle peut rejoindre la scène si
elles quittent le métier haifa devra
trouver une autre source de revenus et
elle le sait déjà ce sera moins
confortable que la danse
j'aime quand à dire que deviennent
riches mais ça rapporte plutôt bien tu
dois me conviant par mariage ça dépend
approximativement en moyenne un peu plus
de 600 livres égyptiennes par mariage
mais c'est bien par rapport au niveau de
vie ici oui plutôt
dieu merci nous par rapport au niveau de
vie moyen c'est largement suffisant et
ça me convient
[Musique]
haifa monte sur scène c'est l'attraction
de la soirée
et pourtant il ne reste plus qu'une
centaine de danseuses égyptienne dans
tout le pays mais face à cette
désaffection ce sont désormais les
étrangères qui les remplacent cette
jeune femme est coréenne
elle est venue au caire faire son
apprentissage de la danse orientale
elle se produit depuis plus d'un an dans
les mariages traditionnels comme chaque
semaine elle bien prendre son cours de
danse chirac à ussel son professeur mais
dans la clandestinité car officiellement
les cours de danse n'existe pas en
egypte
[Musique]
oui et ça pour moi c'est un art c'est la
danse de leur pays c'est un héritage
alors je comprends pas pourquoi ils
doivent lutter contre tous est interdite
si j'étais égyptienne je rêvais pouvoir
apprendre la danse dans une école mais
n'y a pas d'école pour cela je comprends
pas toutes ces contraintes et cette
hypocrisie
[Musique]
je
on
or
danseuse ici a besoin de deux agréments
le premier du comité de censure et le
second de la police des moeurs c'est la
police en fait la danse n'a rien à voir
avec ça à quoi sert la police ici on
parle aujourd'hui d'art propre en egypte
un art qui serait conforme à la norme
islamique et à la vision des plus
traditionalistes cette réalité commence
à toucher les chanteuses
certaines d'entre elles doivent faire
face à la censure de leurs clients
ici le décolleté de la dame sera floutés
avant d'accueillir ses pensionnaires
najlae que l'on voit ici est tunisienne
elle est venue faire carrière au caire
comme beaucoup d'autres ce clip sera
jugé pornographique est interdit de
diffusion
l'interdiction demandée par m nabil
al-wahsh et les sanctions
administratives iront beaucoup plus loin
il a voulu faire un exemple qui pourrait
même faire l'objet d'une jurisprudence
[Musique]
le ministre de l'intérieur qui peut
déchoir la nationalité d'une chanteuse
ou mettre fin à son titre de séjour dans
le pays
c'est ce qui a été fait pour najlae qui
n'a pas respecté l'éthique et les
valeurs du pays
les scènes de nu et ses déclarations ont
été l'objet de marocaine dans une
émission qu'elle avait excité le cheval
que l'on voit dans son appareil on était
fier le réalisateur a même dû cacher
est-ce que ça se disent ça se dit je les
poursuit le jugement me donnait raison
elle a dû quitter le territoire et
s'exiler au livre bien sûr je veux qu'il
y ait une jurisprudence pour toutes ces
chanteuses mais aussi pour les actrices
et acteurs aux oeuvres et aux propos
indécents
je veux qu'il soit interdit de voie de
presse et de toute médiatisation
[Musique]
la chanson n'a pas été touché par ce
retour à l'ordre moral et la rigueur
religieuse
mais le cinéma en porte désormais les
stigmates
nombreuses sont les actrices à s'être
voilée c'est le cas d'anne turc
la plus célèbre actrice du cinéma arabe
qui a fait couler beaucoup d'encre elle
incarnait dans son dernier rôle non
voilée une danseuse de petite vertu
le film sera interdite de diffusion et
elle se voilera après le tournage
[Musique]
au début je n'ai pas pu concevoir de
porter le voile
car mon amour pour le cinéma était trop
fort mais je sentais que le voile était
une obligation et je me demandais quelle
était la relation entre le voile et la
fois donc je suis allé voir un
théologien un homme très sage en qui
j'avais confiance
je lui ai dit que je n'avais qu'une
question à lui poser
le voile est ce que c'est essentiel est
ce le gage du paradis nyon tu lâches des
doutes sur le fait que ce soit une
obligation j'ai répondu oui j'ai des
doutes
c'est une obligation at il répondu donc
entre la promesse du paradis est celle
de l'enfer j'ai choisi mon choix
personnel pression sociale ou intérêt
financier à la nature qui milite
désormais pour le port du voile pour
youssef chahine qui l'a révélé à l'écran
elle a été achetée comme beaucoup
d'autres par l'arabie saoudite
beaucoup d'avoir ça va jusqu'à 2
millions de tonnes à 4 me dont il y en a
deux au général
ils n'ont pas beaucoup d'argent les
acteurs au commencement de leur vie à la
fin si si ça m'arrange canton l'europe 4
millions c'est un tout petit peu cinglé
l'un des célèbres lada be
nous nous sommes rendus à l'institut
politique du care rencontrer le
spécialiste et matt gâte
[Musique]
à
l'émergence d'un cinéma et d'un art
propre comme on l'appelle ici est
concomitant à l'influencé économique et
politique grandissante de l'arabie
saoudite dans la région il y a un
certain nombre d'acteurs et d'actrices
qui refuse formellement de faire des
scènes osées c'est ce qu'on appelle le
cinéma pro c'est en réalité un nouveau
marché adaptée aux critères de certains
pays du golfe
les critères d'adhésion pour le cinéma
propre c'est de produire un cinéma qui
soit en entière conformité avec la loi
islamique qui n'y est donc pas de scènes
de baiser qu'il n'y ait pas un homme et
une femme ensemble seul dans une même
scène
ces gens là ne font que répondre à la
demande d'un nouveau marché celui du
cinéma propres ce n'est pas un nouveau
mode de vie qui l'ont adopté c'est juste
une nouvelle économie
un rôle de composition qui se joue à la
fois à l'écran et dans la vie gauche
tout cela pour vendre l'arabie saoudite
non c'est juste l'émergence d'une
nouvelle économie qui a fait naître ce
cinéma et compte tenu de la dégradation
du pays et de son système politique
il n'y a pas eu de préservation de la
culture égyptienne et du cinéma égyptien
du coup les producteurs vont là où il ya
de l'argent et ses productions qui sont
exportés reviennent sur nos chaînes du
coup les égyptiens subissent aussi cette
production il faut ré égyptienne is et
l'egypte en quelque sorte
le voile a ainsi fait son grand retour à
l'écran comme dans les rues du caire et
du reste du monde arabe
malgré le succès que ces chanteuses
rencontrer la contreverse qu'elles ont
suscitées ruby et 110 sont loin d'être
devenus des archétypes et des modèles
que l'on limite mais à l'heure des
printemps arabes
sandy se prend à rêver que la révolution
permettent la question du choix et ouvre
le débat
85% des égyptiennes sont voilées est ce
parce qu'elles n'ont pas accepté le défi
de te ressembler la liberté ne portent
pas exclusivement sur la question de
porter le voile ou non c'est la liberté
d'agir de choisir de pensée qui importe
sinon nous n'aurions pas fait la
révolution si nous ne cherchons pas la
liberté et dans ce cadre là le port ou
non du voile ne sera qu'un choix
personnel est plus un choix pour être en
conformité avec la société nana
[Applaudissements]
la révolution a initié une volonté de
changement mais ce sont aujourd'hui les
islamistes qui en récolte les fruits la
confrérie des frères musulmans est un
parti en voie de normalisation et les
salafistes eux militent pour exporter le
modèle saoudien en egypte depuis
l'effondrement de la dictature de
moubarak l'influencent des salafistes et
grandissante dans la société
notre vision c'est que l'islam est une
religion politique et militaire la
religion c'est la politique
à ce titre les salafistes s'intéresse à
la politique et c'est aussi une religion
militaire la religion gère et régit tout
si les salafistes n'était pas actif
jusque là c'est parce que nous étions
menacés par la sûreté de l'état
[Applaudissements]
les libertés individuelles des femmes se
sont considérablement réduites ces vingt
dernières années sous l'influencé
grandissante des frères musulmans dans
la société
mais aujourd'hui les salafistes veulent
aller encore plus loin que les frères
musulmans qu'ils tiennent pour des
réformistes
le militant ali talât tu se revendique
du salafisme le plus extrême
[Musique]
je suis salafiste jihadiste mon souhait
le plus cher est de m'engager auprès des
moudjahidine en afghanistan comme le
souhaitait nadal je rêve d'une égypte
qui vivait comme on vivait au temps du
prophète que tous les musulmans en
egypte et dans le monde vivent selon les
enseignements musulmanes doivent être
méconnaissable
pour éviter toute tentation comme il est
dit dans le saint coran
le voile est comme une porte qui doit
rester fermée à la promiscuité des
inconnus les frères musulmans sont trop
laxistes notamment sur le port du voile
et la mixité hommes femmes
les frères musulmans sont trop mou trop
ouvert sur ces points là
soutenues et financées par l'arabie
saoudite les salafistes veulent
instituer une théocratie en egypte à
travers des talk-shows islamistes
l'arabie saoudite cherche à exporter son
modèle en egypte mais aussi dans le
reste de la région
dans ce talk show on y fustige l'
influence néfaste des danseuses et des
chanteuses cette émission s'attaque
aussi à la permissivité des étudiantes
qui se rendent sur leur campus sans le
voile les étudiantes voilées elles sont
assurées d'échapper aux flammes de
l'enfer et c'est une ancienne actrice
égyptienne
reconverti dans le prosélytisme
religieux qui anime ce probable les
vidéo clips sont l'oeuvre de satan ses
chansons séduisante ont pénétré nos
foyers et elles finiront par corrompre
nos enfants elles détruisent la base de
notre éducation
[Musique]
face à un avenir politique incertain et
à la menace islamiste
nous avons demandé à 110 et rubis si
elle envisageait de se voiler de changer
leur registre
[Musique]
certaines personnes peuvent considérer
l'art comme illicites
mon but dans l'art c'est de transmettre
l'idée de liberté
le toit est ce que tu porteraient le
voile l'idée de porter le voile
j'y pense ce n'est pas impossible mais
quand seul dieu le sait 610 se partage
désormais entre l'égypte et l'étranger
pour poursuivre sans entrave sa carrière
ruby n'a fait aucune concession
son avis est plus tranché nous a donné
rendez vous sur les bords du nil et le
choix du lieu n'est pas anodin c'est là
où se retrouvent à la nuit tombée et en
cachette les jeunes couples amour pour
elle la liberté n'a pas de prix
je suivrai tout simplement je ne suis
pas prête à changer à porter le voile ou
quoique ce soit d'autre
j'aime trop la liberté je suis comme ça
les bimbos d'égypte sont l'expression
d'un paradoxe dans une société en pleine
islamisation elles sont apparues comme
un moyen de ventiler la frustration de
la population tolérer jusque-là ce
marché pourrait bien disparaître si les
frères musulmans et les salafistes
poursuivre leur accession au pouvoir
l'egypte reste encore le premier marché
pour ces chanteuses mais aujourd'hui
face à un avenir incertain
c'est le liban pays multiconfessionnel
qui a repris le flambeau
les nouvelles chanteuses libanaises sont
pour la plupart non plus musulmane et
chrétienne
[Musique]
moore
tous
où
[Musique]